So this is our continuing solution for
this multipart quiz. We have begun issuing instruction MUL 4,
so the question is now, what goes into the fields of the reservation station?
And also, which RAT entries going to modified? The modification of the RAT entry
is going to be easy because it's going to be the RAT entry for R1. So
the correct answer here is R1. The RAT entry for R1 is going to be modified, and
we modified with ROB4. Before we do that,
however, we need to read out what is the RAT content for R1 and R2.
And we find that it's ROB2 and ROB1. So, the answer here is going to be that,
this reservation station entry for the multiplication is going to have two tags,
for R1, ROB2, for R2, ROB1. And it's not going to have either of the values.
We would only put something here if we could actually get their actual value
from wherever it is. But because we need to wait for ROB2 to get the value and
we need to wait for ROB1 to get that value, which simply leave these empty.
So that concludes the correct answering for this part of the quiz.